[Music]
thing for 45 seconds last time anywho
mission impossible dead reckoning i'm
excited i love love this franchise and i
love me some tommy cruz we are the gold
standard
so leave a like if you can that would be
very much appreciated subscribe click
the notification bell because we got a
lot coming up uh starting at the end of
this week oh boy so much coming your way
guys let's get into this
[Music]
oh nice like a james bond theme song
days of fighting for the so-called
greater good
are over hey
this is our chance
to control the truth
the concepts
of right and wrong
hey like for centuries to come
[Music]
you're fighting to save an ideal that
doesn't exist my patch
never did
you need to pick a sign
oh my god it's mirroring the first movie
[Music]
the mummy i know i can't think of that
throughout this
[Music]
oh
this is the magic hour mission
impossible
shay wiggum
[Music]
yes
[Music]
doctors
[Music]
i think they actually destroyed that
bridge
wow
wow
sexy
ah
and then tom just hits right into the
ground yeah i like to see from the other
guys when they jump off the rooftop
the only way faith wants to go out
is in a place of innocence who's been
promoting top gun in this race
it's just a cg model who got him scanned
in that's insane my nipples got so
chilly so early on god that last stunt
is crazy he's supposed to go into a
parachute right now that's just fine
like superhero landing
yeah yeah he's gonna have one of those
batman flight suits there are surprising
amount of callbacks to the first movie
in this one i mean not only do you have
what's that actor's name henry cherny
oh wow you just
whipped that one out having him back
there and a sit down and conversation
across him that's the scene in the first
movie when they had puts the gum on the
mirror and on the water tank and that
back then was a big dunker style like oh
my god that's insane now it's like
nothing for doctors yeah climb back to
that scene even at one point with the
key with haley atwood there's like a
magic reveal like i don't know i call
him doing that in any of the other
movies but the first one yeah one
fighting on top of the train on top of
the train
it's very much reminiscent of the first
movie which is often uh i think that one
is a kind of an unrecognized one in this
franchise because that one's not much
action it's mainly just you know
espionage dialogue driven and where you
know it's become much more of an action
franchise so it's cool to see it you
know really embodying those things
christian core is a hell of a writer so
to see it going back to a little more of
those and i think you got to have a more
intense expansive story especially if
you are making this a two-parter i don't
know if part eight is going to be called
dead reckoning too but this is
essentially a part one to the last the
last two months in this franchise but it
looks uh along the lines of what i've
been loving about the mission of
possible franchise since mccoy took over
keeping the action very vital and very
intense but also keeping it dark the
ensemble's so big it's so big now yeah
it's like morphed into a show again
or the first one was we're getting rid
of all the cats yes and then we're just
gonna zero in on a few people yeah and
this one has a big ensemble again it got
like everyone vanessa kirby rebecca
ferguson straight out of metal gear
solid yeah yeah absolutely you got benji
and you got luther yeah haley atwell for
sure is michelle monaghan gonna be
coming back i hope so she's just they're
gonna have to go and bother her again
saving the world doing her philanthropic
work i thought like he would eventually
end up with rebecca ferguson but it
looks like a lot of the romantic
chemistry is going to be coming in the
form of haley atwell who do you choose
tom i know hopefully you've got some
both action-oriented and acting-oriented
leading ladies to choose from they
should be the polyamorous ethan hunters
that's who we should get you also have
your your wife who i'm sure still very
much worried about you at all times
she's
around
i hope that the last very last movie
comes all the way back there we got to
save your old wife you know jeremy
renner well he they gotta find a way
maybe they'll surprise us maybe he'll
step in when you least expect it or
something and one of our loyal
subscribers raghu who i know is here in
the comments right now he mentioned that
there were vibes of this trailer that
gave a lawrence of arabia vibe not so
much not gonna work for me no man no no
that's the end of the mummy right there
this is the continuation of that
franchise as well
nick arcs into ethan hunt remember nick
that's right man that's your favorite
mummy now that's my the definitive mummy
as far as i'm concerned and he did say
that palm clementine was in this movie
as well and i think that's who the one
asian girl fighting who as an assassin
is that would make a lot of sense yeah
that bleach blonde hairdo and this one
they all get kind of political but this
one seems to be the most overtly
political at least in the marketing for
mission impossible the movies tend to
have some type of it's not no one's a
big takeaway a mission apostle tends to
be the political aspects of it so i
don't hear people [ __ ] about it but
here they seem to really lean heavily on
it because they're talking about like
controlling the ideals and that did get
metal gear solid vibes honestly
a lot of this so it seems to me at least
they're on the brink of a some type of
big-ass war breaking out well yeah or
just like worldwide unrest and i get the
sense yeah to make it very modern it's
probably some kind of mcguffin or or
world ending stake scenario that has
something to do with information and the
distribution thereof they're fighting
fox news and cnbc and exactly they're
fighting
on and everybody
but kind of i mean you know i'm sure
they'll make some kind of grand sci-fi
macguffin out of all that stuff but yeah
i mean that's very relevant to the now
and i feel like the further we get
through these movies you know you have
biological warfare you have geopolitical
tensions you have ecological things and
and james even if you look at james bond
movies they often derive their big bads
from those things too but there's a bond
fleur to it yeah yeah yeah yeah and i
mean you know i'm sure that comes from
the intermingling of both franchises
influencing each other as they move
forward sure sure yeah but yeah there is
something that looks while incredibly
action-packed as per the earmarks of
mission impossible like it will also
have more of that james bond not to even
slight the previous mission impossibles
though because they can get pretty
intricate in terms of the plotting they
want you to follow yeah but yeah this
definitely had some of that elegance and
i think the choice to
do most of the trailer set to music and
really choose when to use sound effects
and when to use dialogue helps to
enhance that level of elegance almost
even though everything you're seeing is
so rough and tumble but i thought this
trailer was great i mean that final
stunt though looks crazy but i feel like
there's probably something even bigger
in store yeah well it looks like it's a
good write as much as we've talked about
it hearkening back to the first film it
definitely does but it seems like two
they're coming through the entire
history yeah and all the different where
are the dumps and places
and the dueling motorcycle we might get
a knife very close to an eye because my
prediction would be that rebecca
ferguson has to lose that eye in the
knife fight oh yeah probably never
forget and never forget only use guns
from now on all right people well what'd
you think leave your thoughts down below
we watched top gun maverick this week as
well a lot of tom cruise
and obi-wan and stranger things yeah